with life decisions is it better to be
decisive and take actions to move
forward even if sometimes those
decisions are wrong as opposed to being
paralyzed by indecision and fear thus
getting maneuvered on by life I asked
this because I struggle with life
decisions and have trouble committing to
one path duty eclectic interests after
listening to your podcast I'm thinking
it's better to be aggressive and
maneuver on the battlefield of life as
long as I'm prepared to adapt rather
than sitting around and letting
circumstance dictate my actions well it
sounds like you kind of answered his own
question which is good yes it is better
to be aggressive it's better to be
decisive this does not mean burning
bridges and I think we've talked about
this before it doesn't mean that you
just you just say I'm quitting my job
right now because I'm gonna go start a
new life as a whatever your new job is
gonna be right I'm gonna start a
business selling widgets and I'm just
gonna go all-in because I'm committed
sure well you you know how long it takes
produce those widgets and whatever you
know so there's a lot of issues that you
know it's there's a way though to to
mitigate risk on your decisions and
actually at the at the camp we were in
up in Maine there was a lot of guys that
were you know listen to podcast and one
of them really good really good guy he
was talking to me about his business and
the business which I'm not gonna go into
any details but he's basically saying
look I got this business it's going well
I wanted to do better and I'm kind of
weighing this decision between bringing
on we says no I want to bring on like
six people mmm to really help expand and
grow and all that stuff he said but if I
do that and we have a couple rough you
know if we hit some bad luck I might be
upside down and and not be able to
handle it and and what I really am
scared of is like that's not just me but
it's now it's my family I got a wife and
I got kids and now I'm hedging the the
the comfort and safety of my family so I
don't know what to do
and I said okay well do you have to go
all-in right do you have to
around tomorrow you know what we're
going all-in I'm gonna hire these six
people we're gonna expand and hopefully
if everything goes right we'll do really
well mm-hmm
you don't have to do that you don't have
to put that much on the table instead I
said I said well how many people do you
actually really need right now and he
said probably one or two it was like
okay why don't you bring on one and and
start to see where that goes and be
prepared to look for another person to
bring on too and then as those two
people work out and you're starting to
fill their labor every day and they're
had they have work to do because you're
expanding the cool bring on three and
and guess what if you hit a hiccup and
things start going sideways for whatever
reason that's cool you don't have those
additional four people or three people
on board that you're paying payroll to
every month which is normally what kills
businesses or one of the common things
that kills businesses so it's the same
so that's that's a good example right
and he was he thought to himself and he
looked at me said absolutely I'm gonna
go do that and so he's probably back at
his job right now running his business
and probably hired a person to start
expanding not hiring six people and
putting all of his chips on the table
where it's a cool gamble let's say the
percentage of living winning is 70%
you're like yeah I'm just gonna do it
there's a 30% chance you luve lose and
now your family has no house and no food
so that's not what we want to do so why
not just put some of your chips on the
table and you can still win and make a
little bit you still you still improve
your position so we got to do that with
life - like I said you don't quit your
job to start building widgets when you
don't know what you're doing you got a
bit why not just build the widgets in
your spare time yeah see what up yeah
start putting those things on the
internet start seeing how they sell
start getting a little income from them
let them grow and then finally when you
feel like the balance start to tip maybe
there'll be a last-minute jump will you
be like okay now I'm gonna go for it but
what you're committing to is something
solid something tangible and something
that's making money right we're not
jumping in and committing to something
that's an unknown we're gonna commit
some to something that's known and and I
think it's important to note that that
right there is not a lack of commitment
and this is your these like you know
people on the interwebs
they'll be like you know why you haven't
made it yet because you haven't
committed 100% that's why you if you
want to do it you gotta commit with
everything you've got
well and so what people think is okay
well I'm just gonna quit my job because
I'm gonna go for him to commit and then
I'll be successful because this guy over
here told me if I committed I'd be
successful it's actually not true you
can be a thousand percent committed to
something and you can still fail I got
bad news for you that's the reality you
know that's the reality of do you think
the people at blackberry weren't
committed to their game you know what I
mean
you know but what happened a blackberry
mmm it's it's they were they were
committed but they made some bad
decisions and guess what now
BlackBerry's not really in the game
anymore
well they I think they changed games I'm
not a hundred percent sure but people
think that that because you didn't quit
your job and go all in and put all your
chips on the table that you're not
committed and I actually don't agree
with that and I'll get here's my example
if okay I think that commitment is
actually harder to do when it's a
long-term commitment that you're going
okay you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
stay at my job but I'm gonna work three
hours a day on this other thing I'm
gonna be manufacturing I may be making
my widgets three hours a day when I get
home at 10 o'clock at night I'm gonna go
until one o'clock in the morning making
my widgets that's commitment it's
actually smart commitment it actually in
some ways takes more commitment to do
that than it does just to quit your job
and say I'm all-in because now you're
holding your balancing all these
different things you carry your
shouldering more of a burden so that
actually takes more commitment the
problem is that people they get weak and
after the fourth night of making widgets
at 10 o'clock at night they go yeah I am
loads I'm good it's cool I'll have a job
I have a job and so that's weak I you
know an example be what if you could get
in excellent physical condition in 3
hours but it was just like the hardest 3
hours that you could imagine think about
that and your body would transform from
whatever crap condition you're in right
now into a specimen and it's going to
take 3
of just hell how many more people would
be an amazing condition I think a ton
more because committing for three hours
to something even it was gonna be super
bad people would be able to do it what
takes more commitment and the reason
everyone's not walking around like a
perfect specimen is because it doesn't
take three hours it doesn't take three
weeks
it doesn't take three months it takes a
daily grind that goes on for years that
you have to hold the line on on the way
you eat on the way you exercise on your
life and that takes real commitment yes
so it isn't a lack of commitment it's
planning it isn't a lack of commitment
it is mitigating risk and don't confuse
again I I think that the person that
commits to something and still maintains
this other income stream for example
that person is at least as committed if
not more committed than the person says
you know what screw it I'm going all-in
over here I'm forgetting about you know
quitting my job that's not a smart move
yeah and it takes more that's actually
easier well that's my point it's easier
in many ways to go you know what I'm
quitting this day job I'm quitting my
nine-to-five I'm sick of that cubicle
I'm sick of that construction site I'm
just going all-in over here that is an
easier move that takes less commitment
then saying I'm gonna shoulder the
burden of working 15 18 20 hours a day
for the next two years until I can get
this thing stood up enough to where I
can execute it yeah yes it's almost like
people are conflating the commitment you
know it's like they almost people want
to want to want to do a big show of
commitment by quitting their job but
it's more of just a show of commitment
to show you're committed or you're not
kind of thing yeah and then so a lot of
times with these big shows of commitment
becomes just an immense amount of
stupidity you know yeah yeah meanwhile
you can either come in or don't commit
you know yeah sure if you don't quit
your job and you make widgets and you
don't commit sure it's like all right
you got you can facilitate your non
commitment yeah yeah I dig here's your
real job your nine-to-five job is in the
neighbor
or to you not committing yeah fully yeah
but by no means is that you know no poor
oaf yeah yeah and it's important to note
that don't confuse and this is another
mistake so people make mistakes on
either ends of the spectrum the other
one is don't confuse planning and
mitigating risk with not taking action
because that can happen to you have to
make things happen every single day
that's what you have to do if you don't
take action if you don't move which is
what this guy's asking about then yeah
you're paralyzed and you're never gonna
get anywhere but all you have to do is
chip away at that thing you gotta make a
little bit of movement every day yeah
you want to write a book and this is
something I'm familiar with the house
I'm writing books I'm writing another
book right now
hell yeah and you know what I got to do
I got to chip away at that thing every
day every day
yeah every day there's your commitment
words a day 45 minutes maybe an hour
that's what it takes and guess what if I
can't get that hour for whatever reason
guess what I'm gonna get to 20 minutes
I'm gonna get 30 minutes I'm gonna get
something to get in there I'm gonna do
work because I'm gonna be close to my
goal than I was yeah that's the way it
is I think you can see that live didn't
you yes it was my honor that's but
that's where it happens where else is
gonna happen right yeah we were flying
back from Maine I was you know
Echo's cruising good yeah I think I fell
asleep coupledom yeah you were kind of
in and out but I was hammering I was I
was doing what I have to do mm-hmm
because if I don't do it then when's
that what I'm gonna get that hour that
was that was four hours I had right
there yeah it's light technically 5:00
yeah couldn't get my computer out for
the first a little bit oh yeah they
don't let you so whatever
oh good yeah I was kind of at times I
was peeking over your shoulder like
reading okay then I see how was it I saw
the name Kenny Williamson in there Oh
to this good man being composed yeah I
think that all that sounds like kind of
obvious you know when you're saying it
I'm like yeah okay yeah yeah yeah got it
yeah or you know or at least the part
where it's like it's a daily thing like
you gotta be to have a progress you know
like you got to take that step you know
do it um sounds obvious but men how many
times and I know this like my friends
and you know whatever oh you go on not
online or whatever and you see people
complaining about you know stuff never
happens for me you know FML you know FML
means yes stuff never happens to you
that's right and stuff never happens for
you that's right yeah that is life
doesn't happen for you in life yeah you
gotta go and make it you know I've
explained to my kids you want to make
money
you have to take that money from someone
else you have to take it from them then
people are just gonna walk up and give
you money Yeah right that doesn't happen
that's never happened to me in my life
no one has ever walked up and given me
money you gotta take that money they
gotta give it to you that you got to
make them you got to take it from them
yeah they want that money too mm-hm so
what are you gonna give them that's
gonna make allow you to take it from
them yeah that that so yeah guess what
nothing's nothing happens for you that's
right nothing does happen for you you
have to make it happen yeah that's the
default aggressive mindset that you're
gonna make things happen
you're not gonna sit around and wait for
things to happen it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen oh well guess what
I read a story about this such and such
a person and they just walked into this
you know agency and they they thought
they looked did a really good job and
now they're famous okay that's great
base your life on that percentage chance
of happening it's not happening yeah I
actually I actually look at that and
just think the chances of anything like
that happened to me or zero nothing good
is gonna happen to me like that that I'm
just gonna get a good deal like that's
not happening zero yeah so if you're
gonna get it you're gonna have to make
it happen yeah next question you're
saying that should be the red flag right
there then right basically for the for
someone who's like nothing you know when
am I gonna get my big break or or you
know nothing happens for me kind of
thing that should be the red flag right
one it's like yeah yeah
as soon as you're talking about the fact
that you're not that things aren't
coming to you yeah yeah yeah that should
be a real big red flag nothing is gonna
come to you not happening not happening
you got to go and make things happen and
once you have that attitude I'll tell
you what it's a game-changer yeah it's a
game-changer once you realize that that
book that's so good that's in your head
is not gonna write itself
yeah once you realize that widget that
you have this plan for isn't gonna build
itself then you'll realize like okay
I'm gonna have to make these things
happen and even then guess what you can
make a widget that no one wants to buy
and you can write a book that no one
wants to know wants to read and if
you're not okay with that
which is another thing that happens
people say well you know no one will
like it okay well if that's what you
think well then don't even write it
unless you want to write it for yourself
yeah then write it for yourself and cool
B be proud be stoked be happy yeah it's
interesting too let's say a book book
all right for example it this kind of
reminds me of where you know how let's
say I don't know me let's say oh I'm a
pretty good writer in fact I even wrote
a book before whatever and then my
friend on Instagram face well whatever
someone my neighbor whatever they write
a book and they they release it and then
they write another one and let's say
it's not even really that good but it's
out there they're like look at my new
book and you know they got people's
support oh that's awesome you wrote a
book and I mean while I'm like kind of
sour grapes a little bit I'm like I'm a
better writer than than that person
meanwhile I didn't write anymore over
here yeah yeah back in the day long time
ago you know but you know I'm saying I'm
in that arena you know and I'm kind of
in my mind hating on this people there's
people that hate on them that never even
wrote a book in the first place yeah I'm
a better writer I'm a better film guy
I'm a better writer I'm a better fighter
whatever there's all kinds of people
doing that all kinds of people that that
will just be saying I you know I I I was
a better whatever fighter jiu-jitsu
player carpenter whatever you name it
yeah meanwhile taking no action software
engineer I could have done that
why didn't you yeah exactly right I'll
tell you why because you weren't
committed yes and the commitment that
we're talking about is a night yeah
night
that's what tension or early in the
morning or in the middle of day whatever
you know it how you said like you're
you're not doing these enormous shows of
commitment like either you're committed
or you're not if you're committed it's
gonna show itself like a question you
know a lot of people again back to the
guy who's like hating on his neighbor
doing quote-unquote mediocre work like
oh that's John that's not that good he
didn't want it you know what this just
made me think of this sometimes you'd
meet a guy that was say I'm going to
SEAL training and and they kind of be
brag about it and you could see in their
eyes that that right there was good
enough for them oh like I'm going to
SEAL team training yeah you know no one
it calls the SEAL team training but
that's the kind of person cuz they just
want to and you died here guy you guys
saying that yeah I'm going to SEAL
training the guys that generally have a
better chance or guys that you know you
say oh what are you doing in the Navy
and they say oh you know I'm um you know
just got done with a school and I'm
starting hoping to go to SEAL training
you know I you have to pry it out of him
yeah that guy's a better chance the guy
that's already bragging yeah basically
indirectly bragging because he's
implying that he's gonna make it
those guys gonna have a little bit more
of a rough time now this doesn't mean
they're not this doesn't mean don't be
confident yeah but that's what I'm
saying is some people that are like I'm
going for it they're happy with just
saying I'm committed I quit my job and
this one I do they're happy to let
everyone know that yeah but what they're
not happy to do is grind that's what
they're not happy to do and that's where
that's where you that's where you make
your money right or where you make your
goods or where you become successful
yeah there's I was losing somebody and
they were talking about like commit like
people have goals I want to be a singer
or whatever I want to be a CEO that's
money
oh you can form up in a hell LC today
and you can become the CEO exactly right
so that's kind of right that's part of
the point right there it's like okay you
want to be CEO because you see all this
cool stuff on wherever about being a CEO
but really what you're pursuing isn't
necessarily being this it is but what
you're pursuing where you're gonna end
up and where you're gonna find success
is CEO if you're pursuing that day to
day of you need a CEO it's like I said
this before and it's it's on the surface
it's lame but it's it's actually really
accurate like if you want to be a
gangster you have to do gangster stuff
every day it's not just like posing with
your guns it's like you got to kind of
you got to put in that work kind of
thing you know so if you're gonna be
like you can't just be Jaco and start a
podcast and just in in you know put out
a book and that's it and start
collecting money it's not like that you
gotta you gotta go through you know
however old you are many years there's
other steps involved laughs and I used
to joke about you know cuz when we
started Ashla on front obviously which
is me and him and we'd see some other
guy out then to be a CEO of something
and we'd be saying well that guy's the
CEO and you look at their company and
the company has them only one person or
three people right it bro yeah on the
CEO hey I'm the CEO of taco podcast yeah
no it's just you and me there's no CEO
going on here yeah we're cruising too
hard yeah yeah yeah that deal you gotta
focus on the right things as opposed to
the wrong thing check